The son of a late Beatle makes beautiful sushi in Los Angeles, next on Grubber's Delight.
Hey there food lovers. I'm Catherine Cronenberg and you're watching Grubber's Delight,...
...the best show on the Internet for anybody who loves to eat.
We're running down a list of some of the hippest...
...and tastiest celebrity-owned restaurants.
And next on our stop is a sushi bar owned by the son of a Beatle.
John Lennon may have declared, "I am the walrus,"...
...but his son Julian is becoming the king of uncooked fish,...
...as his West Hollywood hotspot "Blowfish Sushi to Die For"...
...has become a popular hangout for the young, hot and famous.
With a quirky menu featuring such items as Godzilla, Animal Style and Ego Rolls,...
...and delicious specialty drinks like none other,...
...it's no surprise that the place is popular.
But with its nightclub-like atmosphere of thumping dance music, suede walls,...
...and flat screen TVs playing Japanese anime,...
...it becomes clear pretty quickly why the hip and fun sushi joint...
...is one of the most popular in town, filled with great sushi choices.
And when the son of one of the most famous and beloved musicians of all time...
...is the owner, it doesn't hurt either.
I'm Catherine Cronenberg  for Grubber's Delight, reminding you to eat well.